Schönen guten Tag, mein Name ist Ujag. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnesgespräch durchführen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich Herr Doktor.
Danke, bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, okay?
Okay, danke schön.
Gerne, wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Edward Langerperda.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vornachnamen langsam buchstabieren?
E-D-W-A-R-D Edward.
Ja?
L-A-N-G-I-N-F-I-L-D-E-R Langerperda.
Herr Langerperda, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 46.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
8. April 1979.
Okay, wie groß sind Sie?
1,84 Meter.
Und wie schwer sind Sie zuzeit?
70, Entschuldigung, 80 Kilogramm, Herr Doktor.
Okay, danke für die Informationen, Herr Langerperda. Was können Sie für Sie tun? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie zuzeit?
Herr Doktor, ich bin heute gekommen, weil ich drückende Schmerzen hinter dem Brutbein habe. Sehr stecke Schmerzen.
Herr Langerperda, seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Ich habe 45 Minuten diese Schmerzen.
Okay, alles klar. Strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwohin aus?
Ja, die Schmerzen strahlen in meinem linken Arm und in der Unterkiffe aus, Doktor.
Okay, Herr Langerperda, haben Sie auch Luftnot?
Ja Doktor, Sie haben Recht. Ich habe die Schmerzen in meinem linken Arm und in der Unterkiffe aus, Doktor.
Ja Doktor, Sie haben Recht. Ich habe Luftnot, ja.
Okay, Herr Langerperda, ich möchte das Analysegespräch hier unterbrechen.
Warum, Doktor?
Das kann eine Notfallsituation sein, deswegen möchte ich Ihre Vitaparameter wie zum Beispiel Blutdruck, Sauerstoff, Sättigung messen. Okay?
Doktor, ich habe viel Angst. Werde ich die Kerben oder?
Bitte machen Sie sich keine Sorgen. Also Sie sind jetzt im Krankenhaus. Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, hierher zu kommen. Sie sind in guten Händen bei uns. Okay?
Danke schön, Doktor.
Herr Oberarzt, ich möchte das Analysegespräch hier unterbrechen. Ich vermute, dass der Patient an Myokardinfarkt akutes Koronasyndrom leidet.
Deswegen möchte ich die Vitaparameter überwachen. Danach werde ich einen EKG schreiben und danach werde ich Brut abnehmen, um die Herzenzima kontrollieren.
Aber jetzt bin ich in der Kürfung und möchte das Analysegespräch weitermachen. Darf ich?
Ja, bitte.
Vielen Dank. Herr Langenfelder, wir haben schon Ihre Vitaparameter kontrolliert und ich habe Ihnen schon ein Schmerzmittel gegeben. Wie fühlen Sie sich jetzt? Besser, oder?
Ja, ich fühle mich besser, Doktor. Danke schön.
Sehr gerne. Herr Langenfelder, hatten Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden? Oder ist das das erste Mal bei Ihnen?
Ich hatte zum ersten Mal diese Beschwerden, Doktor.
Okay. Haben Sie ein Medikament gegen diese Schmerzen eingenommen?
Nein, Doktor. Ich habe Ihnen gesagt, ich habe seit ungefähr einer Stunde diese Schmerzen.
Ja, Sie haben recht. Wie sind Sie zu uns gekommen, Herr Langenfelder?
Ich gehe mit meiner Frau, Doktor.
Okay. Können Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben? Sind Sie eher drückend, stechend, brennend?
Ja, die Schmerzen sind drückend, Doktor.
Ja, drückend.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt, wie zum Beispiel Belastung, Ruhe?
Ja, Doktor. Ich muss ein bisschen denken.
Die Beschwerden sind plötzlich aufgetreten nach einem emotionellen belastenden Streit mit meinen Nachbarn.
Mein Nachbar ist gestorben gestern und ich habe viele Angst. Nach dieser Situation hatte ich diese Beschwerden, Doktor. Ich denke.
Okay, alles klar. Herr Langenfelder, Sie leiden unter Brust, unter auch Dyspnoe.
Ja, Dyspnoe, Doktor. Ich habe auch Dyspnoe, Doktor.
Ja, treten die Atemnot nur bei Belastung oder auch in Ruhe?
Ich habe Belastung, bei Belastung. Ich habe Atemnot bei Belastung, Doktor.
Okay.
Ihr Vater ist gestern gestorben?
Ja, gestern. Mein Nachbar ist gestern gestorben.
Der Vater von Nachbarn, richtig? Ja, ja. Mein Vater von Nachbarn, ja.
Okay, alles klar. Ist Ihnen übel oder mussten Sie erbrechen?
Ja, Doktor. Ich habe ganze Übelkeit, ja. Und zweimal erbrechen.
Haben Sie im Erbrochen Blut bemerkt?
Ich habe nicht im Blut meine Erbrochen bemerkt, Doktor.
Okay. Herr Langenfelder, haben Sie Fieber, Schütterfrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Was? Fieber? Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich nicht fieberig, Doktor.
Okay, leiden Sie unter Kaltschweiß oder Schweißausbrüche?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich habe starke Schweißschwitzen, ja.
Ich habe keine Schweißausbrüche. Okay. Nur Schwitzen.
Ist alles in Ordnung beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Doktor, ich habe Zuckerkrankheit. Deswegen muss ich viele Mal auf die Toilette gehen.
Vor allem nachts, ungefähr drei oder viermal muss ich jeden Tag auf die Toilette gehen, Doktor.
Okay, und ich glaube Sie haben auch eine Schlafstörung, richtig?
Ja, richtig.
Haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Ich habe Durchschlafprobleme.
Okay, und ist alles in Ordnung beim Stuhlgang?
Ich habe sehr lange seit verstoppt, Doktor.
Okay, und nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Ich habe ein Medikament von DM gekauft, aber ich kenne es nicht jetzt.
Wie heißt es? Vielleicht können Sie mit meiner Hausart kennen, Doktor.
Ja, sehr gerne. Also, Herr Raminfelder, wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Mein Hausarzt ist Herr Doktor Meier.
Okay, also nehmen Sie ein Abfüllmittel ein, nehmen Sie...
Ja, bei Bedarf aber. Nicht sehr gerne.
Okay, alles klar.
Herr Raminfelder, leiden Sie unter Husten?
Nein Doktor, ich habe keine Husten.
Okay, sind Sie schon vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft, so wie viermal gegen Covid-19, Doktor.
Das freut mich.
Herr Raminfelder, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie an Blutzuckerkrankheit leiden?
Ja, ja. Seit wann, darf ich fragen?
Seit acht Jahren habe ich Blutzuckerkrankheit, Doktor.
Ja, und nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Ich nehme dagegen Icandra 50 bis 1000 mg, abends und nachts, zweimal täglich ein.
Abends und nachts, ja?
Ja, nachts.
Okay, noch sonst etwas?
Außerdem habe ich seit sieben Jahren Bluthochdruck, Doktor.
Siebzehn Jahren, ja?
Nein, sieben Jahren.
Sieben Jahren, okay. Und was nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Ich nehme dagegen 8 mg, morgens, einmal täglich.
Okay. Herr Raminfelder, kontrollieren Sie Ihre Blutzuckerwerte und Blutdruckwerte regelmäßig?
Ja, Doktor, ich gehe regelmäßig zu meinem Hausarzt.
Und ist alles in Ordnung?
Ja, alles in Ordnung, ja.
Okay. Sonst noch etwas? Haben Sie irgendwelche anderen Erkrankungen?
Ja, vor etwa neun Monaten hatte ich eine Salmonellinfektion, nachdem ich rohes Fleisch gegessen hatte.
Und wie wurde dieses Problem behandelt?
Mein Hausarzt hat mir eine Antibiotik geschrieben, aber ich weiß nicht jetzt, wie sie heißt.
Okay, ich werde Ihrem Hausarzt kontaktieren für diese Details, okay?
Danke schön, Doktor.
Okay. Und sonst noch etwas?
Ja, an meiner Daumen-Berlin-Region habe ich eine Kleidennabe, die nach einer Operation wegen einer Verlassung einstanden ist.
Ich hatte vor drei Jahren einen Fahrradunfall, ja Doktor.
Okay. Vor drei Jahren hatten Sie einen Fahrradunfall, deswegen hatten Sie eine Operation und Sie haben eine Narbe?
Ja, ja, ja, vielleicht eine Kleidennabe, ja.
Okay. Herr Langenfelder, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf außer genannten irgendwelche anderen Medikamente ein?
Andere Medikamente? Ja, ich habe manchmal Kopfschmerzen, dagegen nehme ich bei Bedarf Ibuprofen, 15 mg, Doktor.
Bei Bedarf, ja?
Ja, ja.
Okay. Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden, ich meine außer dieser Handoperation?
Ich hatte keine andere Operation, Doktor, nein.
Okay. Herr Langenfelder, sind Sie allergisch gegen irgendwelche Medikamente, Pflanzen oder Nahrungsmittel?
Ja Doktor, ich reagiere allergisch auf Pollen.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Das auslöst sich mit vielen Hautentzündungen, Renitis, Konjunktivitis, ja. Nauseen laufen, Tränen aufhören, ja.
Okay. Und sonst noch etwas, irgendwelche anderen Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten vielleicht?
Ich habe keine anderen Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten, Doktor.
Okay. Herr Langenfelder, rauchen Sie?
Ja, leider Doktor.
Seit wann und wie viel?
Ich rauche seit 5 Jahren etwa 12 Zigaretten täglich, aber früher habe ich 15 Jahre lang 30 Zigaretten pro Tag geraucht, ja.
Okay, aber Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, das Rauchen zu reduzieren, ja. Ich gratuliere Ihnen.
Wenn Sie möchten, können wir Sie dabei unterstützen. Wir haben ein gutes Programm hier im Krankenhaus mit dem Rauchen aufzuhören. Okay?
Doktor, ich wäre Ihnen dankbar, wenn Sie mir helfen können, weil ich viele Mal den Zigaretten auf geraucht suche, aber ich habe ihn nicht bestanden jetzt.
Okay, sehr gerne. Wir können darüber widersprechen nach dem Aufnahmegespräch, ja.
Danke schön Doktor.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke etwa eine Flasche Bier täglich, ja.
Okay, bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine routine Frage. Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Drogen habe ich nicht konsumiert.
Super. Herr Langenfelder, leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck oder Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja, mein Vater ist mit 55 Jahren an Bronchiakarsinom gestorben Doktor.
Mein Beileid, Herr Langenfelder.
Danke schön.
Und Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter lebt mit einem Hypovisadenum und Zuckerkrankheit Typ 2. Sie lebt in Altenheim jetzt.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich bin Einzelkind Doktor.
Wie ist Ihre Familienstadt? Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie hierher mit Ihrer Frau geboren sind.
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Wohren Sie zusammen?
Ja, ich lebe mit meiner Frau zusammen.
Okay, und haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe einen Siblinge Doktor, 19 Jahre alt.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Mein Sohn leidet am Mobus Kuhn, meine Tochter ist gesund.
Es tut mir leid, dass Sie hören.
Herr Langenfelder, was Sie von Beruf?
Ich arbeite als Heisungsinstallator.
Okay, ich bedanke mich Herr Langenfelder. Das waren meine Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja Doktor, ich habe viel Angst. Was habe ich?
Ja, Herr Langenfelder, wie gesagt, machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Ja, wir werden alles für Sie tun. Ich vermute, dass Sie eine Durchblutstörung am Herz haben.
Deswegen möchte ich Sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen.
Danach werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen und ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Sobald die alle Ergebnisse da sind, werde ich Ihnen die weiteren Informationen mitteilen.
Okay, wie lange dauert diese Untersuchungen?
Diese Untersuchungen können ein paar Stunden dauern.
Also ein paar Stunden müssen Sie sicherlich bei uns bleiben.
Wenn wir etwas Auffälliges finden, kann es auch passieren, dass Sie ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus bleiben sollen, Herr Langenfelder.
Haben Sie viele Erfahrungen über diese Beschwerden, Doktor?
Ja, aber natürlich. Wir arbeiten hier als Team und unser Team hat viele Erfahrungen über dieses Thema.
Okay, danke schön Doktor. Ich warte auf Sie. Danke schön.
Sehr gerne. Bitte nehmen Sie Platz im Wartezimmer. Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und ich würde gerne über ihn berichten. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Danke schön. Herr Edward Langenfelder ist 46 Jahre alt, 1,84 Meter groß und 80 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Langenfelder stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit 45 Minuten bestehender, drückender Brustschmerzen vor.
Der Patient sei plötzlich aufgetreten und mit der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Er berietete das, die Schmerzen nach einem Streit mit dem Nachbarn aufgetreten.
Der Vater von Nachbarn sei gestern gestorben, deswegen hat der Patient Angst vor Tod.
Die Fragen nach früheren ähnlichen Beschwerden und Kaltschweiß wurden verneint.
Der Patient klagte über Belastung abhängiger Dyspnoe und Hyperhydrose.
Bei der vegetativen Anamnese seien die Folgenden bekannt.
Nuktyrie 3-4 Mal in der Nacht, seit Langem bestehende Obsipation und Insomnie in Form von Durchschlafstörungen.
Der Patient nehme gegen Obsipation ein Abfühlmittel bei Bedarf ein, aber der Name von Medikamenten sollte geklärt werden.
An Vorerkrankungen nannte der Patient die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus.
Die Schmerzen würden in den linken Arm und in den Unterkiefern ausstrahlen.
Vorerkrankungen nannte er seit acht Jahren bestehenden Diabetes mellitus, seit sieben Jahren bestehende alte Hypertonie.
Vor neun Monaten diagnostizierte Salmonella Infektion wegen reues Fleisch, die mit Antibiotika behandelt worden sei.
Der Patient nehme 50-1000 mg Abends und Nachts, 8 mg morgens ein.
Außerdem nehme der Patient über Provenz 500 mg gegen CfLg bei Bedarf ein.
Vor drei Jahren habe er sich eine Tenarregion Verletzung beim Fahrradunfall zugezogen, die operativ behandelt worden sei.
Deswegen habe er eine Nabe an der Keloid in der Tenarregion.
Der Patient habe Polenallergie, die sich durch Rhino-Konjunktivitis äußert.
Er sei Raucher und rauche zwölf Zigaretten täglich seit fünf Jahren.
Davor habe er 30 Zigaretten täglich, fünfzehn Jahre lang geraucht.
Er trinke eine Flasche Bier täglich, Drogenkonsum wurden verneint.
Der Patient ist in der Familienanamnese, ab der an, dass der Vater mit 55 Jahren an Bronchiakarzinom verstorben sei.
Die Mutter leidet an Diabetes mellitus type 2 und Hypophysis adenoma.
Sie lebt in einem Altenheim.
Der Patient sei Einzelkind verheiratet, habe Zwillinge, die 19 Jahre alt seien.
Der Sohn leidet an Mobus Crohn und der Patient wohne mit seiner Familie zusammen.
Er sei Heizungsinstallator von Beruf.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf ein akutes Coronasyndrom aus, da der Patient typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Der Patient leidet unter Angina Pectoris, drückende Brustschmerzen, Dyspnoe und Hyperhidrosa.
Diese Symptome und die Schmerzen strahlen in den linken Arm und unter Kiefer aus.
Diese Symptome sprechen für ein akutes Coronasyndrom.
Als differenziertes Diagnosen kommen Lungenembolie, arterielle Dissektion, Pneumothorax in Betracht.
Um meine Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich zunächst bei den Patienten die Vitalparameter überwachen und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Hautfarbeveränderungen, Problemen bei Inspiration vorhanden sind.
Danach würde ich ein EKG schreiben, um die möglichen Pathologien zu beurteilen.
Und ich würde auch eine Echokardiographie durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien zu beurteilen.
Zusätzlich ist eine Labouruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnose zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Blutbilds, CAP, BSG, Herzenzime, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Gerinnungsparameter, Elektrolyten, Blutgasanalyse bestimmen lassen.
Und ich würde auch eine PTCA durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien genau zu beurteilen und gleichzeitig eine Behandlung durchführen.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich die Patientensstation aufnehmen und einen Venösenzugang legen.
Und ich würde Monab Therapie, Akutmaßnahme Therapien durchführen, Morphin, Sauerstoffgabe, Nitroglycerin, Acetylsalicylsäure, Beta-Blocker.
Danach würde ich ein Kardiologisches Konzil anfordern, um die Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Ich würde den Patienten Lebensstilveränderungen empfehlen, also regelmäßige Beweglichkeit, Nikotinkarenz, Alkoholkarenz, eine gesunde Gewichtsenthalte enthalten.
Die optimale Blutzuckerwerte zu halten und niedrige Blutdrucke zu halten, sind sehr wichtig bei diesen Patienten.
Als langzeitige Therapie würde ich ACH, Beta-Blocker, Antipatensivtherapie, Antidiabetische Therapie verschreiben.
Ja, und ich würde gerne den Patienten zu einem Herzkatheter Labor und einer kardiologischen Klinik einweisen.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren, Herr Oberarzt.
Herr Kollegen, können Sie uns die PTCA aufklären?
Ja, gerne. Ich werde sie über PTCA aufklären.
Percutane Transderminale Chronoplastie ist die radiologische Darstellung der Herztransgefäße.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns, die Durchbrutstörungen genau zu erkennen.
Gleichzeitig können wir eine Therapie, eine Behandlung durchführen.
Bei dieser Untersuchung schieben wir einen dünnen flexiblen Katheter durch den Leichtenarterien oder Armarterien in die verengte Gefäße vor.
Dann verabreichen wir ein Kontrastmittel, um die verengte Gefäße sichtbar zu machen.
Danach erweitern wir die verengte Gefäße mit einem Ballon. Am meisten sollen wir einen Stent einsetzen.
Diese Untersuchung kann sowohl zu diagnostischen als auch therapeutischen Zwecken benutzt werden.
Diese Untersuchung dauert ca. eine Stunde.
Es gibt einige Komplikationen, wie z.B. Nachblutungen oder Blutgerinnsel.
Nach der Untersuchung soll der Patient ein paar Stunden im Krankenhaus bleiben zur Beobachtung und betroffene Beine ruhig stellen.
Herr Kollegen, würden Sie den Patienten operative Behandlung empfehlen?
Wenn es keine Therapiemöglichkeit beim PTC gibt, dann können wir eine Bypassoperation durchführen, um die Reakanalisation zu behandeln.
Wie können wir die pulmonaren Emboli ausschließen?
Bei der pulmonaren Emboli können wir die Dymäe als Labouruntersuchung bestimmen.
Wir können auch eine Thorax-Angiografie durchführen, um die mögliche Pathologie zu beurteilen.
Wie können wir die Herzinfizienz ausschließen?
Als Labouruntersuchung können wir BNP bestimmen lassen.
Wir können auch eine Echokardiographie durchführen, um die Herzinfizienz auszuschließen.
Die Anamnese ist sehr wichtig bei einer Herzinfizienz.
Bei einer Eudemie, Acid, am Bauch, Nektarie, paroxysmale, ist die Nektarie sehr wichtig bei einer Herzinfizienz.
Okay, Herr Kollegen, ich habe alle Fragen gestellt. Bitte gehen Sie auf unser Infodesk und nehmen Ihre Zertifizienz. Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg für Ihre Arbeitsweg.
Vielen Dank, Herr Oberarzt, Sie sind sehr nett. Danke schön.